I mean the first thing that's important
to know is that many people are
interested slash obsessed with what they
eat the data that's come out of animal
studies at least it's far more important
when you eat and what you eat and this
was a fantastic study a few years ago by
my friend Rafael dicabo at the National
Institutes of Health and Bethesda and he
had 10 000 mice on different diets
hoping to find the perfect mix of carbs
protein and fat and it turns out that
the only ones that live longer were the
ones that only ate once a day and so
that if we're we're not mice but I think
that we're close enough to mice that it
tells us a lot but I still think the
best bang for the longevity Buck is to
do both well eat less often and eat the
right things need motivation watch a top
10 with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best David Sinclair and my take
on his top 10 rules of success enjoy
rule number two get more fatty acids
even with a normal diet you often don't
get enough of these omega-3 fatty acids
which are the types that we don't make
ourselves if you're only meat and you
don't eat fish you eat animals besides
fish you're not getting a lot of them
and they're the building blocks of the
brain so we need a lot of them and
they've been shown in a number of
studies to help with many different
things from wound healing and of course
depression now what are the sources well
if you eat fish you're probably in good
shape you've got salmon and mackerel
Krill sardines these are good sources of
Omega-3s and these are giving us the
dhas and the epa's because there's three
different kinds of these right well
there are lots but the three main ones
that people talk about are EPA and DHA
the EPA is the more important one you
want to get at least a gram of that
sometimes people say get 1.6 grams of
this ratio of EPA to DHA and women about
1.3 grams and that's been shown to
greatly improve memory and counteract
depression now that if you're a
plant-based person you can't obviously
get as much you have to focus on other
types of food that have what's called
Alpha linoleic acid or ala which is
converted slowly not efficiently about
10 of it gets converted by the body into
the two types we just mentioned that are
important the DHA and importantly the
EPA
Focus then on flaxseed walnuts chia
seeds that's where you get your ala
linseed oil is is where it was first
discovered ala linoleic acid I use that
to polish certain things I keep wood
looking good cricket bats you put it on
there but you can also you can consume a
little bit there's a lot of it in there
as well and there's there's one other
thing I want to mention that isn't in
that list of three which is a
monounsaturated fatty acid called oleic
acid which is really important and I
mentioned it earlier it's a component of
olive oil and avocados and I have that
included in my supplement every night
along with these other components as a
reason convert to seaweed salads I would
be remiss not to know that you can
actually get if one of the few plant
sources you can get DHA in the EPA from
is is from seaweed is that right it is
right well I don't know if you get
enough of it I think it's really a good
thing to consider and talk to your
doctor about it to take at least a gram
of these omega-3 fatty acids every day
so we know we should be consuming these
Omega-3s but but why what are they doing
in our cells so it turns out these
Omega-3s actually form a structural
component of the brain they insert along
with other fats in in the brain so fat
is actually good for the brain a lot of
our brain is made up of these fats the
reason is that the nerves aren't naked
much like an electrical wire you don't
have them lying around your house naked
they actually be wrapped with insulation
tape or insulation insulating material
and that's what these fats do and these
are membranes that wrap around it's
called the myelin sheath and these fats
actually some of them are Omega-3s and
the more Omega-3s you have in your diet
the more you'll have in those membranes
and that protects from inflammation and
damage and helps the nerves function and
repair if they get damaged rule number
three start intermittent fasting
intermittent fasting now is the most
popular diet in the world
uh hopefully it's not a fad because this
is probably the most effective diet
that's ever been
promoted in on the planet
um even for children I'm not suggesting
malnutrition or starvation by any means
but having three meals a day plus snacks
uh is a calorie overload or even for
children in the most cases and you can
tell just by the amount of fat a kid is
carrying as to whether you're over
feeding your kid and if you're if you
have an obese child and I know it's very
difficult because in my family we
struggle with this as well but the
effects on that child will Echo for
decades perhaps even towards the end of
life they will still have the memory the
epigenetic memory we call it of having
been obese as a child and so one area
that I'm researching and going to be
communicating about
is the effects of our lifestyle not just
on adults and the elderly but even on
children
yeah
I want to come back to that shortly
um
but before we leave the topic facing
less
he said intermittent fasting is the most
popular diet or way of eating in the
world now
and you know there's brand new blog
posts podcasts YouTube videos every day
coming out on this
um do you think of intermittent fasting
as different to time restricted eating
and at least I'm sort of diving in here
is
you know when I see patients I have to
be very clear with what I'm asking them
to do you know very specific so they
really understand what I'm recommending
and I think for some people intermittent
fasting is one meal a day for some
people it's you know 16 hours without
eating and eight hours a day where i'm
consuming food then you also have time
which it's an eating where it's eat all
your food within an eight hour window or
a 10 hour when you're a 12 hour window
and I think there is a little bit of
confusion out there as to what these
terms actually mean so how do you put
that together for people if they're
asking
oh I
I don't think that it's helpful to have
these all these different names it's
essentially just eat less often that's
how simple it is skip a meal skip the
snacks
um so intermittent fasting time
restricted feeding uh to me it's all the
same thing it's just uh don't keep your
body filled with food that's pretty
simple the amount of hours the more you
can spread it out so 18
for me is is a good good number
um 16's okay
um you know I I hate within two hours so
I get
basically 22 hours which works for me
um but here's the the really important
Point
um it's not complicated you do what you
can you start skipping meals start with
one dinner or breakfast and then if you
can do that then try to go longer
um it's not the other really important
thing is if you try to do what I do
from a standing start you will fail
there's no question it's too hard your
body will freak out it'll feel tired
your brain will be distracted and you'll
go straight to the fridge you need to
give yourself time it can take a month
to get there and one of the adaptations
is your liver needs to learn to put out
glucose to maintain steady levels so
it's not like this through the day and
and that takes it takes a while but once
you're at the state that I'm in and your
microbiome is optimized and your liver
is very happy with its existence then
you you will find it very hard to go
back to eating the old way
um and you also generally look a lot
better as well which is a nice side
effect rule number four lessen glucose
intake so having high blood sugar is
just known to accelerate aging there's
no question about it but why though why
yeah why so there's a couple of reasons
that there's a very simple reason and a
very um I guess practical explanation
which is that the glucose that
circulates in your body
can be used for fuel but it can also
inadvertently get attached to your
proteins okay yeah and then when you've
got this glucose attached to proteins
they malfunction so that's part of this
buildup this way you want to have some
intermittent fasting restricted feeding
just turn over these
glucuronidated proteins okay and one of
the ways to measure diabetes yes is to
measure the glucose that's attached to
your hemoglobin which is an abundant
protein in your red blood cells and
doctors take that measurements called
hba1c that tells you how much glucose
you've had in your body roughly for the
last month
because hemoglobin lasts the in the body
for about three months and it's turned
over and that number gives you a good
idea of whether you've been eating badly
and or you've got type 2 diabetes which
is the inability to utilize that blood
sugar or no energy but or trending
towards correct yeah that's the big is
that not the big thing that most people
that are going to go that are having
this monitor they're not probably a type
2 yet but they're trending in that
direction if they don't do something
about it for sure and that's why it's
important to measure it even when you're
young right you don't want it to be
going up and up and up by the time it's
your type 2 diabetic it's often too late
and so I measure I've been measuring
mine for the last uh over a decade I'll
bet the vast majority of people
listening to this have never done that
or do it once every three years in some
random lab test that they do right yeah
so well doctors don't pay a lot of
attention to it until you're old or
really obese so you're starting to show
signs of type 2 diabetes which will
accelerate your aging for sure so that's
one problem with glucose it'll attach to
proteins and make them malfunction and
it's a sign of type 2 diabetes by the
way the numbers are based on the
percentage of your hemoglobin that has
glucose attached to it stuck to it
anything below five percent it's really
great between five and seven is pre and
then roughly and then over seven then
you've got to you know be worried and
your doctor will start to treat it and
one of the drugs that's used we'll talk
about later I think is metformin but but
what's also important I think is to
understand that there's probably another
mechanism to how this is working because
it's not just about blood sugar
by activating this ampk you mentioned
yes it's
actually I gotta take it a real quick
step back because there are three main
things that keep us healthy when we feel
hormesis or do hormesis you've mentioned
mtor which is sensing amino acids the
ones that I work on are called sirtuins
they measure NAD and a whole bunch of
stress in the body it's a size diet the
one that we're talking about is the
third one which is called ampk and it
registers the amount of energy in the
body
glucose and chemical energy which is
called ATP that mitochondria make yes
okay and as we get older our body makes
less and less energy and ampk is the
control system
in ampk is activated by a bunch of
things which uh include being hungry
and exercising or taking the drug
metformin and that's probably why
they're all good for you because it
turns on these defenses this is awesome
okay I'm getting it all right and so
think of it think of your glucose as
doing two things one is sticking to
proteins and Wrecking the proteins and
you need to turn those over by fasting
or eating less regularly but also if you
always have sugar in your body high
levels either diabetic we're just eating
cake every day yes or or sugar in your
coffee what you're doing is telling the
body there's an abundance right now and
your ampk defenses are not turned on
unless you take Metformin which might
bypass that yeah but what I try to do in
my life is to turn on all of those three
systems the sirtuins with boosting an ed
mpk by taking metformin and exercising
and then the mtor not taking an
abundance of those three amino acids I
mentioned leucine is loose unveiling and
together I think they work as a system
we know they talk to each other yeah and
you tweak one the other works we don't
know what the optimal combination is
yeah that I'm experimenting on myself as
a recording on you brother the ball of
humanity is waiting on you here so let's
let's go also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five eat the right things I
will eat occasional
very occasionally a dessert usually I
steal from others which doesn't count
right exactly but you gotta live life
right what's what's a long life if it's
not enjoyable anyway but what if I also
have found and this is I'll get to your
question a second but my microbiome
right now and stomach is at a point
where if I try to overeat on a steak
which I did a couple of days ago I
actually had a a chicken uh a fried
chicken
specifically for two days I felt
terrible I couldn't sleep it wouldn't go
down so I'm now at a point where even if
I want to binge on meat and fried foods
I just can't it just feels bad
um but what what do I recommend well
what the data says which I try to follow
is
uh that plant-based foods will will be
better than meat-based foods and I know
that there are a lot of people disagree
but one of the facts is there's a few
facts one is that people who live a long
time tend to eat those type of diets
Mediterranean Okinawa diet they're
eating mostly plants with a little bit
of meat and not a lot of red meat and
the other fact is that in animals we
know that there's a there's a mechanism
that's called Mt or Little M capital T
or that responds to certain amino acids
that are found in more abundance in meat
and when it responds it actually
shortens lifespan and the converse if
you starve it of those three amino acids
uh in mostly in meat then it extends
lifespan and there is a drug called
rapamycin which some people are
experimenting with that does that so you
might be able to you know I'm just
saying this here from all my colleagues
we don't know the results here but you
could potentially take a rapamycin-like
drug and counteract the effects of meat
on in the long run
I don't know we should try that actually
we can do that in the lab but uh getting
to the bottom of this what I think is
going on is that just like testosterone
and growth hormone you will get
temporary maybe not temporary
um immediate health benefits you'll feel
great you'll get more muscle energy
but the problem is I think it's at the
expense of long-term Health and
Longevity
well this is actually something I worry
about in terms of long-term effects or
the the cost in terms of longevity it's
very difficult to know how your choices
affect your longevity because the impact
is down the line like
just because something makes me feel
good now
like eating only meat makes me feel good
now I wonder what are the costs on the
line well think about what I was saying
about the trade-offs between
growth and reproduction which is what a
mouse does and a whale that grows slowly
reproduces slowly lives a long time it's
called the Disposable Soma Theory Coke
would just propose that in the 70s
what meat probably does is put you in
the mouse category super fertile grow
fast heal fast and then if you want to
be a whale you should restrict meat and
do things that promote the preservation
of your body is it uh difficult to eat a
plant-based diet that you perform well
under so mentally and physically just
almost I'm asking uh almost like
um anecdotal question unless you know
the science
uh well the signs are still being worked
out yeah but from the synthesis of
everything I've read I try to eat a diet
that's
definitely full of leafy greens
uh particularly spinach is great because
it's got the iron that we need
plenty of vitamins I also
um try to avoid too much fruit
and berries particularly fruit juice
definitely avoid that Sugar High spiking
your sugar is not healthy in the long
run
the other thing that's interesting is we
discovered what are called what we call
Xeno hermetic molecules let me unpack
that because it's terrible name and I
take full responsibility with my friend
uh Conrad Howards the Xeno means cross
species and hormesis is the term that
what doesn't kill you makes you live
longer and and and and be healthier and
so we're getting cross-species Health
improvements by molecules that plants
make and plants make these molecules
when they're also under adversity or
perceived adversity for instance uh I I
understand if you want really healthy or
good oranges you can drive Nails into
the the bark of the tree before you
harvest same with wine you typically
want them to be dry before you harvest
or covered in fungus
and that's because these plants make
these colorful and Xeno hermetic
molecules that make themselves stress
resistant turn on their certain defenses
the sort of genes remember and when we
eat them we get those same benefits
that's the idea and we've evolved to do
so this isn't a coincidence it's my
theory our theory that
we want to know when our food supply is
under adversity because we need to get
ready for a famine
and so we hunker down and preserve our
body and by eating these colored Foods
so I practically speaking if it's full
of color or if there's been some chewing
by a caterpillar caterpillar Organic
Grown locally in local farms I'll eat
that versus a watery insipid light
colored
um lettuce that's been grown in
California rule number six eliminate bad
habits the problem is we've built a
world that's
that's very comfortable
and we were not we did not evolve in
these conditions we are meant to be
typically uh cold and hungry
and in response to those adversities our
bodies fight back and so what the
problem is that we now sit in chairs we
eat as much food as we want we don't
have to walk anywhere or lift anything
heavy and our bodies become complacent
now what was discovered is you need
hormesis what's that that basically
means the what doesn't kill you makes
you stronger
um and so what we do when we exercise
and if we skip a meal what we're doing
is inducing this very ancient very very
ancient billions of years ancient
mechanism that protects our body against
Decay disease uh and the root causes of
Aging in an effort to survive
and so you really want to do the
opposite of what modern life gives you
yeah
one of the things that you recommend
I guess one of the most easy to
understand and simplest interventions
you recommend for people is to eat less
and I think that fits
quite beautifully into this uh idea of
hormesis doesn't say in terms of what
eating less signals to the body and then
what it causes the body to do afterwards
so I wonder if we could just sort of
dive in there into why is eating less
important what signal does it give us
and then how does that impact
the way in which we age
well there are three main longevity
mechanisms that we know of um they have
certain names one's called sirtuins
there's seven of those genes in our body
and we've been working on them for 25
years another one's called mtor the
other one's called ambk the names don't
matter as much as the fact that they're
activated by
by a bit of hunger
um to give you an example in 2005 we we
published a science paper that showed uh
which at the time was revolutionary now
it's just considered obvious but one of
these sotoan genes called search E1
was activated by caloric restrictions so
we found that animals that had been
eating less and had low levels of
insulin and another Factor that's
related called igf-1 insulin related
growth factor
uh that boosted the levels dramatically
of this sort one protective longevity
Gene and then we showed that protects
against DNA damage
and so what we do when we're hungry
uh skip a meal or two which is what I do
every day uh it boosts up our longevity
genes and they take care of us we know
that if we boost the longevity genes in
animals they live longer are they
healthier they stay fitter for longer
and they die much quicker at the end of
life
and you know I think everybody
would know that in in human history
fasting is considered one of the
healthiest things you can do
um and so there's so much evidence that
it's really incontrovertible that
skipping meals is not only good for you
but will make you live longer rule
number seven reset your age before we
get into what we can do today just
because it's a Continuum of this
resetting what my lab and many others
now are doing is racing to find easier
ways to reset the age of the body gene
therapy
it's here but it's not going to be you
know mainstream soon it's always going
to be expensive hundreds of thousands of
dollars of treatment what happens when
you can take a pill that will reset your
age by a year
happy Birthday Dad
take this pill incredible and if you
reset your age by a year every year
that's pretty interesting philosophy and
yeah and there are experiments now where
people have reversed their DNA
methylation age which we can now measure
uh by a couple of years
and that only takes a year so now people
are going back at least their
bloodstream is going back younger than
that year took them forward wow so we
are on the verge of something super
interesting in humanity it opens up all
sorts of questions about what's the
world going to look like for maybe us
certainly for our kids
um but getting back to what we can do
every day
the main concept that I think we all
need to remember
is that our bodies respond well to
perceived adversity
and those of us who you know like to
struggle in life I know you're that kind
of guy it's don't give up just keep
going our bodies respond well to that as
long as you're not doing long lasting
harm
and adversity mimetic which can be
don't eat so much don't eat so often
exercise be cold be hot
there are some other tweaks to that high
pressure oxygen therapy is another
theme
these put the body in a state of
adversity mimicry and what that does to
the bodies it says oh my goodness I
could be dead next week I could run out
of food it could be you know chased down
by that tribe over the hill or a
saber-toothed tiger I gotta hunker down
and become more robust and don't put so
much energy into
these other things you know maybe wound
healing would be one thing you could
take away from for a little bit and put
it into long-term survival
those are the the roles of the sirtuans
remember the sirtuins do two things they
slow down aging on the DNA but they also
go and repair things and if you don't
have an officer to an activity or an
officer two and proteins in your body so
in other words you don't make enough of
these little machines or the ones that
you have are pretty inactive and lazy
who don't have enough of the fuel that
they need to work then you're going to
age more rapidly
um and when the crap hits the fan and
you get a broken chromosome then you're
not going to have as much ability to
repair that you might get cancer
and so what my role or my goal in in my
lab and in my experiments with my body
is to make those processes that respond
to adversity Super Active every day so
that it's slowing down the aging process
until we have the technology to reset
the body and reverse it rule number
eight move regularly well probably it's
for me to say don't walk and don't move
that that's step one if you don't walk
or move
then you're in big throttle when you get
older
um so that's a minimum but if we're
talking about what's what's not maximum
but optimal we don't know that for sure
and it might be everyone's different but
in general losing your breath is
important high intensity exercise you
don't need a lot I just mentioned 10
minutes a few times a week that appears
to be sufficient to give you the longer
term health benefits and what's probably
going on is in part is that we well we
discovered and we published this in 2018
in the journal cell if anyone wants to
look it up that old muscle
starts to think that it doesn't have
enough oxygen even though there is
enough oxygen and it shuts itself down
and doesn't make a lot of energy and the
blood vessels start to be depleted and
it's a just a terrible
feed forward process after that so by
making your body hypoxic and giving it a
stress
both in the you can actually do excess
oxygen or lack of oxygen just you just
want to shock the system then your body
gets to reset
um and and one of the most popular
things to do in the longevity world now
is uh what is it high pressure bariatric
oxygen therapy and that I think is also
resetting this uh this problem that our
bodies have where they are what we call
pseudo hypoxic
um one of the ways that we could reset
that without exercise and without high
pressure oxygen Chambers was using nmn
this molecule that I take it actually
boosted the body's ability to make new
blood vessels that restored the the
ability to measure oxygen in the muscle
um and when we gave it to mice they
could run 50 further without having
trained but the good news is well now
the important point is that the mice
that were young and exercise and got the
molecule in their water ran twice as far
so it's it shouldn't be an excuse to pop
a pill and not do anything but there are
some little changes you can make I lift
weights either around my house I I'm at
a standing desk which goes up and down
here these are changes that I make that
um I'm standing most of the day now and
this will really help it builds the
muscles in your leg and your butt and
your back
that's important now especially for a
male my age where I'm losing one percent
muscle if I don't do something about it
every year but also the hormones
testosterone comes uh from having those
large muscles uh signaled to the testes
and I've been able to correct and raise
my testosterone levels just by keeping
those large muscles in shape rule number
nine get enough sleep even at the
molecular level we understand that sort
1 and NAD play a fundamental role in
controlling your wake sleep cycle sort 1
and NAD are going up in the morning
coming down later in the day getting
your body ready for sleep and in doing
so what they do is they turn on a
particular Gene called BML which is part
of the clock not the hovak clock but the
daily clock the Circadian rhythm clock
and those genes tell the liver to calm
down it tells the brain to calm down and
in the morning tells everything to wake
up again and so what is really important
to understand is if you start to lose
the function of sort 1 and have low NAD
levels you're probably not going to
sleep well but also you're going to age
prematurely and the big problem here is
that sleep efficiency actually declines
with age so we got to work harder at
sleep as we get older just like we have
to work harder for exercise as we get
older to promote brain health yeah
another way of saying it is that as you
get older you lose your ability to sleep
and if you don't sleep well you'll lose
your ability to fight aging and it's
just a feed forward disaster so you've
got to intervene you can intervene with
the kind of things we talk about here
which is eating well exercising and
intervening with the kind of things that
you can take perhaps as a supplement but
now let's talk about what do we do to
make sure we sleep well and we have the
right Rhythm and one of the key things
that I use is Anime nmn is going to
raise NAD levels in the morning I take a
gram of it then but I also when I travel
I use it to reset my body and I
definitely feel that I can avoid jet lag
if I do that there's some other
supplements that a lot of people take uh
magnesium that's good for sleep
l-theanine is another one that people
try I've used it seems to help me
but essentially you just want to calm
down at night don't do your emails too
late relax your brain and then I think a
little counter intuitive one of the best
things that you can do for sleep at
night is actually not something you do
before you go to sleep it's something
you do right away when you wake up you
mean go outside please you've got to get
light right you got to reset your
circadian rhythms and the best way to do
that is put yourself in a situation
where your body knows it's daytime well
you can and but here in Boston where I
live there's not a lot of light in
winter so I actually have some blue
light that I can shine in my eyes to get
my cortisol levels up in a synthetic way
not naturally but whatever you do try to
get some light early in the morning
because that always gives you an energy
boost and helps you reset your skating
rhythms if they're not perfectly in sync
and like the other things we've talked
about today there's lots and lots of
research we're not like just making this
up sleep is important we know this well
yeah even in flies fly sleep it's a
little known fact but before we get to
the humans I want to this is a really
cute study it was a study that was in
2020 in fruit flies they found that if
you deprive flies from sleep they have a
lot of oxidative stress in their gut and
they also have a short lifespan which by
the way could be rescued by treating
them with an NAD booster which is also a
way that we've seen that you can rescue
human subjects from leap deprivation but
even just one night of sleep deprivation
a lot of people say oh you know I'll
catch up tomorrow I'll catch up the next
day whatever right maybe I didn't sleep
well tonight but I can sleep well the
rest of the week one night of sleep
deprivation increases amyloid beta
production by five percent
that's you don't want to mess with
amyloid beta right no that that will
accumulate in your brain it's very hard
to get rid of and I was also shocked to
read that it's not just the brain that
ages if you don't sleep we already know
that if you restrict Rats from sleep
they get diabetes within two weeks
in humans looking at a million people
this study from 2010 capucho Hotel what
they found was that in people that had
very little sleep the risk of dying was
30 higher than those that got a natural
normal night's sleep and the thing is
our brains are getting so much adversity
right now right we talk about a little
bit of adversity being good but we
evolved to have a pretty low constant
low level of adversity popping up now
and then and right now in terms of sort
of like the insults and injuries that
we're taking in in terms of stresses
daily stresses everything changing our
brains are being besieged all the time
we need sleep to reset it's just too
much there's too much to remember
there's too much to cope with too much
anxiety we just are living through a
pandemic this is really stressful times
and just lack of sleep makes it worse
and physically we will regret it decades
later and Rule Number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
learn how your body works let's go back
to what is metformin metformin is a
derivative of plant molecule that
inhibits the cell's ability slightly to
make energy and in response so it's been
acting on the mitochondria yes so
mitochondria in high school we were
taught they're the power packs of the
cell they do a lot more they make amino
acids they make fat they do all this
stuff but we need them for energy
without mitochondria we're dead again in
30 seconds
um and the way and so I'm drawing this
because they're like little bacteria in
our cells they float around and they
make energy for us in fact
like four billion years ago actually
only one billion years ago mitochondria
were free-floating bacteria but were
subsumed by us it's crazy so we have
little pets in our body and they have
their own DNA
which does get mutated over time
the reason
um metformin seems to work one of them
is that it inhibits the ability of
mitochondria to make the energy so
mitochondria are like a hydroelectric
Dam
there's water but in this case it's
hydrogen atoms not water that gets
pumped into a reservoir which is between
two membranes on the outside of the of
the the bubble of the bacterium thing
so not hydrogen atoms are really acidic
that's what acid is lots of hydrogen
protons and when you get a lot of
something it likes to equilibrate
remember they you go from a lot too
little it flows but there's a membrane
in between from the high level to the
low level in so internal is low high is
outside
and the cell puts this little generator
in between that outside space in the
Inner Space
the outer membrane space and inner
membrane so it's what we call it and
this little little power generator sits
there and those protons shoot through a
pore in that protein
and at the bottom is a is a generator it
spins literally if the protein is
spinning at thousands of times per
second whoa and as it's spinning it's
doing a chemical reaction to make what's
called ATP
uh adenosine triphosphate doesn't matter
its name that ATP is chemical energy
that we use
to to live to make things to grow and so
what metformin does is that it reduces
the the ability of cells to make that
those proton gradients it's called and
so you don't build up as much power and
you don't make as much ATP initially
have to do with glucose
why do you give that to a diabetic well
what happens is that there's a process
called mitochondesis hormesis is
adversity what doesn't kill you makes
you stronger and Mido is the
mitochondria are experiencing adversity
or perceived adversity so mitochondria
freaking out I can't make enough energy
I don't have it's not enough ATP
okay and what gets activated is a
protein called ampk
ampk is a regulator of energy in our
bodies that senses when we don't make
enough energy
and what note Foreman does is it comes
in and it activates that ampk step and
now the cells are freaking out that
they're not making enough energy and in
response
they'll make more and so you have a
little drop in energy temporarily when
you take a pill but then the cell
rebounds and starts making a lot more
energy and you actually mitochondria
will multiply you get more of these
little bacteria in your cells so taking
metformin causes a replication of your
mitochondria yeah okay ampk starts
but I still don't know how this ties
into glucose
well when you when you activate ampk you
don't just make more mitochondria but
cells start to put out a new protein
that we haven't talked about new to this
chat are called glute4 and that stands
for glucose transporter number four and
it goes to the outside of the cell
right on the very what we call plasma
membrane and it sits there and now its
job is to suck the glucose out from the
liquid around so it's no longer waiting
for insulin to come around to push the
glucose into the cell it's like yo I
need glucose
to help with this energy creation it
does and it so it makes more of this
protein but it also becomes what we call
insulin sensitive so the little bit of
insulin that you have around if you're a
type 2 diabetic
um works better
okay you get more insulin receptor which
is the protein that senses insulin so
all in all what happens to that cell
just to summarize because it's a bit
complicated is that by tricking the cell
into thinking it doesn't have enough
energy it panics adversity hormesis and
it'll go now and put the protein on the
surface to grab the glucose and be more
sensitive to the hormone insulin that
tells the cell to suck it in
why is that good because then your
glucose levels in your bloodstream will
come down and you're no longer type 2
diabetic there are two reasons I believe
why being type 2 diabetic accelerates
aging why you don't want to have high
levels of glucose my eye try to keep
myself you think insulin is is
irrelevant in this chain
I do it's a signaling molecule okay
um I mean over time your pancreas will
suffer because it has to make more and
more of it but that's not what's aging
your brain and your muscle and all these
other things what's going on is two
things one is that that glucose will
attach to proteins all the time it just
sticks to it and in fact the diagnosis
of type 2 diabetes is to look at an
abundant protein in your body in your
blood that you can access at your
doctor's office and figure out what
percentage of that protein is stuck to
glucose and that's hemoglobin uh in your
red blood cells and if you've got five
percent or less hemoglobin attached to
the glucose you're healthy and then you
get 6.5 you're pre-diabetic and higher
than that you're heading towards type 2
diabetes and that's just all about
glucose attaching to proteins
and glucose attaching to proteins messes
things up and they can really not work
well but that's really not the root
cause of Aging as I've told you what's
also going on is that the high levels of
glucose are making your cells complacent
tons of energy got lots of this stuff
going around the hormones your brain
thinks that it's good you're swimming in
treacle
um and so your adversity and repair
systems the sirtuins they don't work as
hard and so your clock is ticking faster
that's why type 2 diabetics have oh
there's no work as hard or they're
lumbering under the weight of glucose
that's stuck to them interestingly both
so twins will get attached to Sugar but
they also they don't
attached to sugar or sugar gets attached
to them sugar gets attached to them okay
yeah
um but what's also a real problem is
that that adversity system is complacent
and so by keeping your glucose levels
down even at a young age well I'm not
young but even at a young age
um your your body will be in this
adversity State versus abundance and
that can explain why type 2 diabetics
are older when you measure it and also
are susceptible to heart disease
um
dementia and even certain types of
cancer and why metformin the drug that
keeps your glucose levels down and
activates this mitoormesis defense
doesn't just protect you against type 2
diabetes
it by looking at tens of thousands of
patients who have that have taken
metformin they also have lower levels of
heart disease dementia Frailty and
cancer
now that we've sort of set the stage for
when we eat which is really important
when we eat we still have to acknowledge
we have to eat sometimes somebody's
gonna you know sometimes you're gonna if
you intermittently fast if you're going
you know 20 hours without food you're
going to have breakfast or you're going
to have dinner
um so yeah there's gonna be something on
your plate
it's really important also what's
actually on your plate that's what this
next half of this episode is about is
what we should eat when we are eating
um
and maybe the best way to start this
really though is to talk about what
definitely shouldn't be or not
definitely shouldn't there should be a
lot less of on that plate right well the
big killer is sugar yeah um glucose
particularly fructose is also pernicious
and if you give animals lots of glucose
and especially fructose they will get
fatty liver disease they'll get diabetes
it's really bad and this one is like
absolutely not controversial right like
we're going to talk about meat later and
people are going to be like really up in
arms but if you say like the big killer
is sugar there's not like a
group of people that's going to come
hunt us down like sugar is bad it is and
and why why well there are two reasons
that glucose is bad when it spikes three
if you include the brain fog but let's
just talk about physiology here uh one
is that you're going to have glucose
attached to proteins that makes them
glum up think of it like caramelized
body parts this will ultimately lower
your longevity reduce the longevity give
you type type 2 diabetes and probably
cardiovascular disease on top of that so
that's one keep those glucose levels
down but also what glucose is going to
be doing to you at high levels is
shutting off those protective mechanisms
remember particularly ampk in the
sirtuins they get Switched Off by sugar
so by having that up for most of the day
if you're eating three meals plus snacks
your defense is against disease and
aging are going to be working at a
minimum
so instead keep those glucose levels low
and consistent you won't get the brain
fog you'll get
fewer proteins modified that'll lead to
disease and thirdly importantly you'll
actually stimulate your body's natural
defenses against disease and aging so
sort of like the the first step sugars
let's get rid of the sugars yeah on that
note by the way I gave up dessert at age
40. so occasionally I steal it and it
doesn't count if you steal it right no I
I think there's like a special little
pocket it goes into it that doesn't
count against indivisible right inside
tracker doesn't pick it up right well
well here's the point um
you can quit something but you don't
have to be Draconian about it I still
like to steal a little you know a few
scoops of ice cream if I see it but I'm
not going to eat a giant bowl of ice
cream every night that's you know a
quick way just to short a lifespan we're
not trying to ruin everybody's Joy no
not at all often when I give talks at
dinners people skip dessert after I'm
I've spoke I feel bad about that well
you remember we were talking about doing
an experiment where we would we would
have a conversation around the table
with people and then have the servers
come with like a birthday cake or
something and just like watch them we
still should do that
uh but yeah so glucose is a bad one
um something else to avoid is super high
protein because mtor it can be activated
but you don't want to activate it all
the time because it's not going to turn
on the autophagy the defenses to recycle
proteins and this one is going to piss a
lot of people off
well yeah I mean there's a lot of people
who believe that carnivore diets are the
best for longevity and for for for
some people a lot of aminos are
appropriate
well certainly if you're an athlete or
you want to bulk up there are short-term
gains you'll feel better if you eat meat
you'll obviously have the protein to
build up that muscle but we can go
through the evidence when you look at
populations of what they eat and how
long they live as well as the short-term
effects when you eat a high protein
carnivorous red meat based diet those
changes are will be good in the short
run but long term there's no evidence in
fact I would say there's counter
evidence to that being beneficial for
Longevity if that's your goal and that's
because of the inhibition of tor in
large part yes the certains will also
get Switched Off by high protein as well
the so aminos are important
we have to have them if we don't have
them we die but you can get aminos from
Plants as well as from animals yeah it
it's funny when I say I've gone
vegetarian recently which is perfect are
you going to get your protein yeah where
do you get protein from but what do you
think plants made of it's also mostly
protein now they're not as bioavailable
so you're getting like two-thirds of the
amount as you would from a steak you
have to work a little harder for it
great I want my body to work harder it's
good for it it burns energy it's also
activating these defenses as we
mentioned so I'm now trying out this uh
a full vegetarian diet I'm not yet vegan
but that actually probably works even
better for longevity as the science will
tell how come that sleep isn't a
homiesis stressor like fasting or
exercise
well it's an it's anti-hermesis
um it's it's necessary for for long life
and health there's no question about
that
um you mean a lack of sleep why doesn't
that yeah yeah why can't you because
you're saying fast it's uncomfortable it
makes you feel it makes you live longer
we're in scary mode we need to extend
our life or else we might not be able to
reproduce before we die so knuckle down
and the same thing goes for exercise
you're under stress why not just why
isn't sleep or a lack of sleep have the
same impact that's a really really
really really
good question no one's ever asked me
that but the answer is that the
longevity the longevity Gene that we
study that's really we think it's really
important
for uh for human longevity too
is part of the the circadian clock
and when you mess that up either through
lack of sleep jet lag or just aging
which diminishes the clock's ability to
form High Peaks and low Peaks
um then it it impacts your longevity
probably because it's affecting
uh your ability to fight disease through
longevity defenses but it's a it seems
to be a positive feedback problem which
is that if you don't get enough sleep
you screw up your aging and then you age
and aging screws up your sleep and by
the time you're elderly you're not
sleeping well
uh and uh you you probably you're you're
under this accelerated aging program
um interestingly that I talk a lot about
NAD which is part of my research
controls this cert one
defense system and the levels go down as
you age but they also go up and down
during the day
as you're waking up you start to make
more NAD and if you disrupt that NAD
level
you disrupt your sleep
and so that's why I tell people if
they're going to boost their energy
levels do it coincident with the clock
as it's rising hit it then which is in
the morning
because I know from experience that if
you take it late at night you're going
to bump up your body make it think that
it's the morning and you'll you'll have
trouble sleeping eat less often those
three words eat less often that is the
one thing that will have the biggest
impact on your longevity based on all
the science we'll talk about today okay
and and this means this doesn't mean eat
fewer calories necessarily it can and
that's good yes that's good but a lot of
people struggle to do that to eat fewer
calories well it comes naturally if
you're down to one meal a day which I am
now uh you shed weight and then you you
get your 20 year old body back that's a
nice bonus but then you you maintain
that weight you have a larger dinner
which is what I do to make sure I'm not
becoming
malnourished clearly we're not talking
about malnutrition or starvation here
it's about packing your calories into a
shorter period of time that's because
packing your meals into a shorter period
almost inevitably means less calories
but it's not
that's not really what's happening here
right it's not just about less calories
it's about what eating less often does
inside of our bodies right and we'll get
to that but really it's not just about
the period of eating it's the period of
not eating that's so important for
boosting the body's defenses against
aging to maximize longevity and we'll
talk about what how that actually works
in a minute but you can still have a
large body
and fast and get the benefits we've in
my lab we've looked at mice that are
obese and trick them into thinking that
they're fasted and they live just as
long as a skinny mouse so really it's
about getting your body into this state
of Defense at any weight though I would
say that there are certain optimal body
weights that it's clear that if you're
carrying excess weight you're going to
accelerate your aging clock what we
don't want people to do is get the idea
though that oh good uh this works even
if you're overweight and so I can stay
overweight and then as long as I fast a
little it's going to be fine that's
that's not what you're saying also right
there are certain body weights uh waist
to height ratios that are optimal for
humans is about 0.5 but yeah losing
weight is is helpful we're not fat
shaming anybody but we're going through
the science this podcast is about what
the sign says not what's socially
acceptable and it is true that if you're
a leaner you will live longer that is a
fact it's not necessary sorry to get
benefits by doing what we're going to
say
but also interestingly as a side effect
of eating less often you will lose
weight I did I've shed about 15 pounds
so since uh the beginning of the
pandemic
and I look better I feel better and it's
a nice side effect but ultimately what
we're going to do here is we're going to
say these are the kind of things you
should consider in your lifestyle we're
going to help you get there we're going
to ease you into it there are some
tricks that make it easier
and ultimately you're going to end up
with a lifestyle and hopefully a body
that allows you to live decades longer
but I still think the best bang for the
longevity Buck is to do both well eat
less often and eat the right things
now I'll preface this to say I'm not a
nut about this I will eat occasional
very occasionally a dessert usually I
steal from others which doesn't count
right exactly but you've got to live
life right what's what's a long life if
it's not enjoyable anyway but I would
have I also found and this is I'll get
to your question in a second but my
microbiome right now and stomach is at a
point where if I try to overeat on a
steak which I did a couple of days ago I
actually had a a chicken uh a fried
chicken
specifically for two days I felt
terrible I couldn't sleep it wouldn't go
down so I'm now at a point where even if
I want to binge on meat and fried foods
I just can't it just feels bad
um but what what do I recommend well
what the data says which I try to follow
is
that plant-based foods will will be
better than meat-based foods and I know
that there are a lot of people disagree
but one of the facts is there's a few
facts one is that people who live a long
time tend to eat those type of diets
Mediterranean Okinawa diet they're
eating mostly plants with a little bit
of meat and not a lot of red meat and
the other fact is that in animals we
know that there's a there's a mechanism
that's called M to a little m capital TR
that responds to certain amino acids
that are found in more abundance in meat
and when it responds it actually
shortens lifespan and the converse if
you starve it of those three amino acids
uh in mostly in meat then it extends
lifespan and there is a drug called
rapamycin which some people are
experimenting with that does that so you
might be able to I'm just saying this
here from all my colleagues we don't
know the results here but you could
potentially take a rapamycin-like drug
and counteract the effects of meat on in
the long run I don't know we should try
that actually we could do that in the
lab but uh getting to the bottom of this
what I think is going on is that just
like testosterone and growth hormone you
will get temporary maybe not temporary
um immediate health benefits you'll feel
great you'll get more muscle energy
but the problem is I think it's at the
expense of long-term Health and
Longevity and when we're talking you
know we've already talked about like the
the real key effects that come from
eating less often to basically turn on
this adversity memetic effect
um there's another really easy way to do
this though right and that's get off
your butt just get off your butt yeah
it's not that hard
um as we say sitting here doing this
podcast but one way I do it is I have a
standing desk so my butt actually
atrophied when we were writing this book
lifespan I ended up with a cramp in my
piriformis muscle which is the way
you're I mean you're what yeah yeah it's
uh it's a small muscle
where is this size doesn't matter it's
right in your hip it goes through that
hole in your pelvis and it's essential
for standing I wondered what that hole
was for yeah it's there's a muscle that
goes through it yes okay all right and
then so the boat was cramped up on my
left hand side so I was limping for
about nine months after we wrote the
book and I thought oh great you know I'm
writing about Health and Longevity and
I've now crippled crippled myself I
eventually got it to go away with a
combination of exercise Physio and an
injection of NAD in my butt which we'll
get to in probably the next episode but
the point here is that sitting down is
bad for us you atrophy you have less
muscle which means your hormone levels
especially particularly testosterone
will go down and you become
you know in pain that's not a good thing
but ultimately if you have not a lot of
muscle in your hips particularly you can
break your bones when you fall over when
you're older and all of that means
you need to get off your butt stand up
even better go for a walk even better go
for a run or cycle to get what we call a
hypoxic state going your body needs to
suck in more oxygen and that has
Remarkable Health benefits and we really
have to work hard at this because I mean
you're saying this as we're sitting in
these chairs right a couple of days
after I sat down in a chair for a long
time in an airplane to get here right
we've got a nice comfy couch over there
that we've been working on like we
actually have to actively like pursue
opportunities to do this to get this to
get exercise to promote this adversity
mimetic effect because our lives are
built around comfort and sedentariness
yes that's true and what I think most
people don't appreciate is that exercise
isn't just beneficial for your Fitness
and For Your vitality it actually can
stop diseases in their tracks exercise
can slow down cancer in fact it can
prevent up to 23 of all cancers from
occurring that's true for cardiovascular
disease in fact it has an even bigger
effect on that 30 reduction just by
doing moderate exercise every week
50 minutes is sufficient or three times
a week with 10 minutes
all cause mortality right so what we all
cause mentality is based mortality is
basically slowing down aging that's a 27
reduction in the rate of Aging just by
exercising the thing you just said I
love this idea of connecting the idea of
all-cause mortality with aging because
as we've presented here as you've been
arguing for quite some time
um most diseases
um which bring us toward the end of our
lives are really just an accumulation of
the symptoms of aging and so if you
bring down the disease rate
across various diseases which is
bringing down all cause mortality you're
really just it's just a another way of
saying we're bringing down aging we must
be exactly and we can also now measure
that with the biological clock the
so-called Horvath clock named after my
good friend Steve Horvath that is now a
measure of the process that leads to all
of these diseases that kill us and one
way that we know for a fact to slow down
the ticking of that biological clock
is exercise
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to activate the power of
manifestation check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
then if the person's doing the vision
board and they're saying when I get my
new car I get my new house I get my new
relationship then I'm gonna feel so
great well then they're back to the
program waiting for it to happen for
them